this is the best wireless charger in the
world and with that it might be the most
expensive one as well but it most likely
isn't worth this so we're gonna go ahead
and take a look I bought this thing
months ago to test it out and it just
came in this is Tesla's wireless
charging platform and it does something
the Apple could not achieve and they
canceled their own air power after
testing it out in it not working the way
they wanted to now personally I'm very
excited about this for a couple of
reasons but it also has one major flaw
so opening up the box right here right
away we are greeted with this cool
design now one thing I did not know is
that it was gonna come with this really
cool charging adapter now I'm really
happy that it has USB type c for the
output it is not a wired plug meaning
you can use a different break if you
wanted to you can replace the cable a
lot of these nicer Chargers have a
dedicated built-in one that you have to
keep and if it breaks you're kind of out
of luck compared to USB type c as you
guys see this has a cyber truck inspired
design which is really cool I wish they
sold this by itself because it's
actually very impressive if we look at
it it actually outputs 65 Watts which is
needed for multi-charging here and if we
compare it to Apple's charger that has a
similar output this thing has a much
smaller footprint and it's barely any
thicker because it does use Gan design
to make it get less hot and put out more
power in a smaller size and as for the
charging pad itself the first thing you
see is this Alcantara this is the same
thing as using high-end Vehicles you
know your Ferraris will have them Lambos
the high-end Teslas will have them this
feels super nice it's grippy but you can
still slide your things around on here
feels very high quality and these edges
are all completely metal this is not
plastic over here so let's pull it out
okay wow that has a lot of way to it
seriously now looking at this cable USB
type-c it looks like you cannot remove
it here but there is a screw down here
and probably some screws underneath in
order to remove this and then maybe it
is replaceable I would hope so but of
course you can change out your power
brick now I'm really surprised that even
the bottom of this is all metal too it
is not plastic so they didn't skimp on
that which they shouldn't for the price
and here we do see that it's made in the
Philippines and it's engineered with
free Power which is a company that has a
design with all those stacked coils so
here's some shots of all the coils
inside of here that give the magic
feature of this wireless charger now
inside the box here we have another
piece of metal look at that this crazy
pattern to make it more durable this is
way Overkill kill it could just be the
outside we have a few screws here this
Rubber and then we have a pass-through
now this is designed so that it will
actually sit in these ridges right here
oh wow it is actually magnetic this is
overkill it literally slides into place
right there you pass your cable through
these cutouts to make it really nice and
neat whoever engineered this they did a
good job and then bang you flip that
sucker over and you got yourself your
own Tesla cyber truck wireless charging
stand now I'm gonna go and take this
base off so you guys can see the test
easier let's plug it in and let's test
it out now my phone conveniently is low
on charge and I do have a 14 pro Max so
as you guys could see it actually sticks
off of the edge here but right away bam
it is charging now on the front front we
have a little LED it's nice and subtle
so it doesn't distract and now let's try
to put something else on there we have
the awesome nothing earbuds too bam
those are charging and let's grab my air
pods I'll just throw them randomly right
over here
bam instantly It is charging as well and
we heard of that chime so the killer
features with all those stacked coils
you can place your devices anywhere on
here and no matter where you place it or
how you place it it is going to charge
no matter what and that's an issue with
a lot of regular wireless chargers if
you don't place it perfectly you're
either going to get a tiny bit of charge
or no charge at all and you wake up to a
phone that's dead or you have to buy a
specific Mac safe one which is great
because it aligns it but it's designed
for one device now the other killer
unique feature is that this thing can
support 15 watts of wireless charging
and not only for one device for example
like a lot of other ones but for three
devices at the same time now there are a
few issues though unless you have small
phones like these ones you may not be
able to fit three phones at the same
time which of course most people will
not do so with some of these larger
phones yeah that's not going to work but
it will do you know wireless charging
for your earbuds and a couple phones at
the same time or realistically for most
people you'd pop one phone on then you'd
pop your earbuds on you don't have to
worry about where it's at and it's going
to work and it's going to charge fast
now the other issue is with your iPhones
unless apple is allowing you to use
magsafe and you have their certification
you're not going to get the full 15 watt
so placing my 14 pro Max on here we're
only going to be limited to 7.5 Watts
the same thing for another phone so you
are going to get slower charging so
let's go ahead and test that out I have
my app right here that is going to see
how fast it is charging I also have my
earpods on here but while that is
running what I think is the deal breaker
is the fact that you cannot charge your
Apple watch with this like you can with
the three in one Chargers that I have at
home so if I place down my Apple watch
nothing is going to happen because it
uses a proprietary charger so for all
the Apple Fans out there that have an
Apple Watch an iPhone maybe some air
pods you're gonna have to have a
separate Apple watch charger and there
is no USB port on here that you can
connect a separate one it's going to
look ugly having that hang off now there
is a chance that Apple could add
standard Qi wireless charging to the
Apple watch with the next update for the
airpods they added in Apple watch
charger charging so you have two you can
use your Apple watch charger or you can
use
um the regular wireless charging and so
you have that flexibility that gives a
hint that they could add it to the new
Apple watches and that would be really
sweet not just for this but in general
now where I'm going to be using this is
going to be downstairs in my basement in
My Hangout room where I can have this
set up you're going down there you have
a few people there one person could set
down their iPhone another person could
toss an Android phone down or any kind
of accessories Android based smart
watches and they will charge up and the
Android guys will charge up super fast
so that is a nice use case scenario but
for most people that are going to use
this by themselves it's probably not
worth it unless you love the Cyber truck
look you have plenty of money and you
want something where you can just set it
down and not worry now it looks like the
test is finished let's hit OK and what
we see is 5 Watts that actually hit the
battery now this tests it what's
actually stayed in the capacity some of
that was used for the screen as well
because it doesn't shut off so I've ran
this a few times sometimes I'll show up
a six six and a half and that is normal
if you're getting 7.5 Watts coming from
the actual coil so don't feel like this
is going to charge your phone super fast
macsafe will be worth it at least at the
low percentages but if you're using
overnight it doesn't really matter that
much so you guys let me know what you
think about this is this absolutely
absurd is this cool that we do have an
air power alternative that has crazy
build quality cool unique design and do
you wish that Apple still went along
with the air power go ahead and click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those videos right over there
that's been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
all right